just a very brief welcome and
introduction to this event it's
University lecture as we all know is one
of the most important times of the year
and it's when we celebrate our most
creative minds but it's also a time in
which we celebrate the academic way of
life the people that we asked to come
and speak are those whom we admire most
because of what they've contributed to
the development of knowledge and I think
I'd have to say that right now it seems
more important to do this than at any
time I can remember and on behalf of all
of us were extremely grateful to
Professor Gilman for giving us the
chance both to honor him and to affirm
the world of the University and I now
turn this over to John cotesworth John
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You president Bollinger and
welcome to this evenings University
lecture this is a night we all look
forward to when disparate parts of the
Columbia community have an opportunity
to come together and to learn about the
academic work of a distinguished faculty
member whose current scholarship might
otherwise remain outside our vision
I certainly count it as a privilege and
a great pleasure to be surrounded by so
many colleagues and students for this
good purpose tonight we will hear from
Andrew Gelman Higgins professor
statistics and professor of political
science professor Hillman is known to
many of you for his public commentaries
making use of statistical methods to
explain politics and polling tonight his
focus is different but the subject is no
less timely and compelling the title of
his talk is the statistical crisis in
science how to move forward
professor Gilman became a faculty member
in Columbia's department of statistics
17 years ago and then two years later in
2002 he received a joint appointment in
the Department of Political Science
before arriving here he had received
undergraduate degrees in mathematics and
physics from MIT and had earned his
master's and PhD degrees in statistics
from Harvard he is the founding director
of Columbia's applied statistics Center
and the author of another of a number of
highly regarded books that have
attracted readers in both academic
circles and among the general public his
book published in 2008 red state blue
state rich state poor state why
Americans vote the way they do succeeded
in appending political myths about
partisan voting patterns and changed the
way we think about elections and
American politics forever professor
Gilman is something of an evangelist
actually an evangelist for improving the
way in which we communicate scientific
research findings to the public he
frequently speaks about the importance
of making statistics visible and
communicating them more effectively to
the public a subject that is also very
much the focus of his admired classroom
teaching
he has also maintained his own widely
read blog for some 10 years now
and is a contributor to The Washington
Post political science blog called the
monkey cage that name I should note
comes from a wonderfully resonant HL
Mencken quote democracy is the art of
running the circus from the monkey cage
professor Kellerman's interests are
wide-ranging he has at different times
focused his attention on police stops
social networks Public Health and
redistricting he has received some of
the some of some mm sorry two dozen
academic awards including their standing
statistical application award from the
American Statistical Association the
award for the best article published in
the American Political Science Review
and the Council of Presidents of
statistical societies award for
outstanding contributions by a person
under the age of 40 as you know from
reading to President to president
Bollinger and from observing many of the
most exciting new developments at
Columbia we are increasingly focused on
bringing the university's vast knowledge
to bear on the pressing problems of the
day doing so has always been and always
will be part of our mission with that in
mind I want to conclude with a quotation
from the speaker we honor tonight
according to Professor Gelman quote
every field worth studying connects to
one's everyday life statistics is not an
isolated field it connects to everything
I am sure that his talk will leave
little doubt as to the rightness of that
claim please join me in welcoming the
2017 University lecturer professor
Andrew
[Applause]
[Music]
hi so the other day somebody sent me an
email they said like did you see this
thing it was in the in the newspaper
about stents so a stent is some sort of
balloon that inflates your artery and it
said that stents do no better than
placebo but this guy said that wasn't
true he read the paper and actually
stents did better than placebo so I was
curious so I read the article and it was
a randomized trial where a hundred
patients got the stents and a hundred
people 100 patients got the sham surgery
where they do the surgery and they don't
put the stent in which don't give me
that look
because they they consented to you know
be randomized and yes it's very safe
like there were no adverse events
apparently and they get like you get
extra good goodies like if you
participate in a medical study they do
nice things to you and they give extra
care so it seemed fair enough and there
there was a difference so that the stent
group did better than the placebo group
but not statistically significantly
better so they said that stents didn't
work eh it's kind of funny I don't
really I'm not an expert on the placebo
effect I think that's what like as a
statistician like I'm not an expert on X
you know for any X that I happen to
study and I but I wonder about the
placebo effect because if you know
there's a 50% chance you're actually
getting the Sham treatment and I don't
know if you get like a 50% placebo or or
what they do the people did this study
was very professional job they knew what
they were doing and they did standard
good practice so they asked people do
you think which treatment do you think
you got and most people most people
didn't know and the ones who guessed
like guessed right about 50% so like it
seemed that people didn't know what they
were getting anyway I looked at the
paper and so I realized the analysis
wasn't quite it wasn't wrong but they
did this thing for all to gain score
where they look at the improvement for
pretest to post-test they didn't control
for differences in pretest between the
groups if you do that you'll get more
statistical efficiency so I thought
maybe I could get the raw data and
analyze just kidding so I but I was able
to read the paper you could actually
deduce from the summary statistics in
the paper what the analysis would be if
you controlled appropriately for the
pretest score so I was able to
reconstruct the analysis that they could
have done but before doing I got really
excited because I could tell from the
differences between pre and post that
when I reanalyzed it would make the
effect bigger and the standard error
smaller it was already at P equals point
two which isn't like good enough it's
supposed to be 0.05 I knew it would get
better so I was so I had to go to work
like I don't know like teach a class or
something I don't under
and so I quickly dashed off an email to
my colleague at the New York Times
saying hey this is going to be big this
is great like you know so then I went
went back and like I was figuring it out
and it did just what I said except the
p-value went from point two - 0.09 which
was like not what it's supposed to do
for the story because it should be it
went to 0.04 and then I would be able to
say look once you do the right analysis
it become statistically significant so
you can see that by doing the right
analysis it changes the story completely
from Stentz don't work distance work the
whole headline changes everything has
changed it's all you know we did it
statistics but well went to 0.09 but
then I realized this is even a better
story really because what's so magic
about 0.05 or whatever right I mean so
the real point is that yeah that's dense
did better maybe the difference Iran
don't care if it's statistically
significant if the difference was not
clinically large and and I I think
actually like there's some issues I
think the study was very well done but
that's kind of the point is I think
there are some issues here and I'll kind
of get back to it that but first I just
want to say it's a pleasure to speak
here I've I've taught here for 21 years
and to have a roomful of collaborators
students family and friends it's really
wonderful it's a privilege to be at any
university but but especially especially
this one and it said that those of you
who have taught know this that to truly
the only way to truly learn a subject is
to teach it and I can assure you that my
students understand statistics very well
because I know that because they've
taught me so much and and I've learned
so much from my collaborators as well so
let me tell you a story this is
something somebody sent to me in the
mail a few years ago I think they wanted
me to make fun of it influence of
Valentine's Day and Halloween on on
birth timing but I actually liked it
I'll show you that the data here from
that from the published article they had
the number they had a data number of
babies born every day for a 20-year
period and you see do you see that the
heart there on the left that's and then
that's Valentine's Day there were more
babies born and then fewer on the week
before and the week after and then do
you see
isn't that cute the witch there yeah
that's Halloween yeah um so it's kind of
funny because like not only are there
more cesarean section births on
Valentine's Day because what shows love
more than but more natural births too
which seems kind of funny like how could
that be
although those of you with statistics
training will know that selection occurs
even on the things that aren't selected
because the natural births are all the
births that weren't induced or cesarean
sections so in fact you get selection
there too anyway this is kind of
interesting it's statistically
significant you can see by those little
stars on someone sent me a paper the
other day it was some claim I didn't
quite believe I looked at it really
carefully and it said it was
statistically significant at the point
one level which you're not really
supposed to say but I just
threw that out for those of you who are
into jargon like that um if you look at
this it's like this is is this real you
know I'm not sure what should you do I
think what we should do is look at all
366 days of the year
so someone made this graph for me this
is the benefits of collaboration
somebody oh hey someone is this
hair-trigger
okay someone made this graph for me you
could ignore the curves this is just the
raw data the total number of babies born
each day of the year you can see fewer
babies on New Year's and and July 4th
and Christmas there's there's
Valentine's Day and Halloween which sort
of like it's not completely clear like
do they really stand out um you see a
wiggling um there are about 52 of those
cycles during the year because it's not
a 28 year period so there's some
confounding of day of week and date
during the year so we probably we need
to do a little bit more analysis if we
just look at this it's hard to know
what's going on with Valentine's Day and
Halloween so okay
someone made this graph for me which I
kind of like because because I hate it
so much because it's you know there's a
principle of statistical graphics that
graphs are comparisons and this graph is
sort of a wonderful way of comparing
what's happening on the 21st of every
month going across which is kind of
goofy it also tells you more babies are
born in the summer and in the early fall
but you can see that much better from
from this graph so this graph is kind of
horrible but I just wanted to can convey
that I thought they would be interesting
to see that not everything we do is very
helpful actually
okay so I'll tell you the rest of that
story once we have the data for you to
see let me move on to the statistical
crisis in science I can start with an
example you might have heard of someone
did a study they wrote they looked at 50
common food ingredients and they scoured
the medical literature and they found of
those 50 in green food ingredients
something like 40 had been discovered to
either cause cancer or prevent cancer
some of them both actually now my point
here is not that onions both cause and
prevent cancer but rather that there's a
problem with how medical research is
often conducted and communicated and a
problem also occurs in other fields such
as psychology medicine and public health
and for example that this dense story
that they're led off with has this issue
like so a study is done some data are
collected and then the result is this
very strong conclusion like something
works or it doesn't work it's actually
kind of funny if you think about it
because it doesn't matter how bad your
data are you always can say it works or
it doesn't work it's like a free
headline I mean you could just be like
you could have a spinner and just
generate random numbers and that would
be enough to get that not not that
anyone would do that just generate
random numbers they might have people
they might but they might be measuring
something that is so noisy that it's as
bad as being random numbers in
particular if you want to study things
like what causes cancer in
epidemiological studies that's kind of
noisy because people can get cancer from
all sorts of reasons so if you study a
small effect you'll be seeing the noise
rather than the signal now it's fine to
see the noise rather than the signal if
that's what you see the but the issue is
if you misinterpret it and then go
around telling people not to eat onions
that would be terrible
um but I'll talk a little bit about
political science rather than psychology
and medicine because local sciences
American politics is what I study
there have been some people we will hear
about political science in a moment but
now it's time to I don't right now it's
time to return to the birthdays so my my
colleague Aki veteran from Finland fit a
statistical model to the birthday data
in its it's a decomposition so we start
with the number we start with the number
of babies born every day between 1968
and 1988 now I just like to interject
here that it's really like great like
students love if you can have an example
where you can find yourself in the data
like you gather data from the students
and then you plot them like which data
point I am I well a lot of you are in
this data right so this is like you can
find yourself if you were born between
1968 and 1988 there are several
components there's a slow trend a fast
non periodic component you kind of need
all of these you need the slow trend
because there was a time when having
babies was less popular than the time
when having babies is more popular you
need a fast non periodic component
because there are just things that
happen like people are in a good mood
and they have more babies than they're
less and a good mood there's fluctuation
we have day of week effect fewer babies
on the weekend and the day of week
effect changes over time it became more
pronounced as the number of scheduled
births went up and then you see seasonal
effect that there's a time more well
known more people born at the end of
summer early fall and then finally the
day of year effect and this model is
cool we did not tell the data we did not
tell the model to look for a New Year's
Day Valentine's Day leap day so forth
our model had 366 parameters one for
each day well plus extra things for the
three floating holidays Labor Day
Thanksgiving and Memorial Day and it
just sort of discovered from the data
what was going on and it picks up you
see it picks up Valentine's Day it's
actually interesting because Valentine's
Day is the only day that has too many
babies all the others have too few well
that's not quite true because December
24th and December 26 have too
any babies but that's because there's a
sort of principle that the baby has to
come out at some point or another so if
you have fewer babies one day you have
to have more nearby but Valentine's Day
is kind of special so I actually really
like that paper that that found that um
then we we got more data this is from
2000 to 2015 and it's similar I want you
to go back and look at this one for a
second you see that the scale on the
y-axis here goes I don't have control
over this thing okay oh I don't point at
that point over there
no okay um if okay if you look at what
happened before there's just a lag
between when I click do I have to say it
are you clicking for me here with it
what's going on with this because I
click it's like a delay okay that the
effects are larger then okay this is
this is what it was like before and you
see like I want to point on there that's
not so helpful if you see that like New
Year's they're about at 80 or so then if
you look at the more recent data the
effects are larger you click to the next
slide please
thank you now there are around 60 so
there's just a lot more induce births
than there used to be but I actually
want to focus on something slightly
different here look at what's going on
around after 9/11 which is a less
popular birthday now do you see that
there's a two-week period where there's
too many babies and that seems to that
violates the baby has to come out
somewhere principle you can't have like
you can't be like scheduling your babies
to for two straight weeks like where the
babies come from
okay so what's really happening is that
the the sort of lump the the positive
thing that's happening after 9/11 is not
it's really not about scheduling birth
that's just a seasonal effect now look
at that seasonal curve do you see how
smooth it is now if we go back to the
previous slide
if we go yes now you see there's like a
bump at the end of September so there
was kind of a this model fit the data
the second model kind of fit the data
well I'm going to go back to the next
slide now please the yes this model sort
of fits the data wrong because it puts
in this slow change in the jet in
November in September it puts it on the
bottom and it should be really on the
third thing so we realize there is a
problem with our model and the prep we
have prior information that's not in the
model and the information is the baby
has to come out somewhere right so our
model said that every day all three
hundred sixty six sixty nine sixty six
days of the year there could be a spike
extra bursts are not enough burst and it
tries to fit what we really need is a
model with a ringing so it says there's
a day with two not enough births and
then the days before and after have to
have extra births to counterbalance that
otherwise it doesn't add up so we didn't
put that in the model and their first
data analysis we got lucky and it sort
of worked out but in the second data
analysis it didn't like discover the
right thing and and so I there are a lot
of points of this example but maybe the
most important is the way that we go
back and forth between our model our
data and our scientific questions we're
not we're sort of circling through
looping back and the stronger the model
we make the more we can learn when the
model doesn't doesn't fit um now the
other relevant point about this is it
demonstrates a principle for mathematics
which is that if you can't solve a
problem embed it in a harder problem
there's a well-known principle of
mathematics if you want to if you can't
prove a theorem about prime numbers
prove it on ideals which is a
generalization of prime numbers if you
can't some an infinite series then you
solve the generating function and
instead of trying to understand what's
happening two days out of the year to
saw it we're gonna have to meet what's
happening in all 366
in statistics this is called the
blessing of dimensionality some
journalists contacted us and they said
what about Friday the 13th 13th it's
like what about fretwell this is just
the 13th you can do more with Friday's
look at the 13th look at that you see
it's kind of funny gives you new insight
into Valentine's Day what's Valentine's
Day that's right so it's the 14th so one
reason Valentine's Day is so popular is
it sitting next to the 13th now that's
not the only reason because you don't
see a peak the 14th of every month but
it doesn't hurt to be next to the 14th
if you want to be getting extra births
the funny thing is this pattern was in
the data already week this was in if I
go back to the earlier graph it's there
we just didn't notice it because we
didn't know what to look and you want to
hear something really funny go back
we're gonna go back to the ugly graph
can I can you go back to the ugly graph
please one more one more
yes stop look at the 13th
isn't that funny I was like oh this
graph is so stupid
it allows you to compare the same day of
every month like I would really want to
compare this actually if you looked at
if I looked at this graph spend a little
bit less time laughing at and more time
looking I would have seen hey what about
the 13th no kidding it's right there
all along but you know of course you'll
only see it if you look at it right okay
the statistical crisis in science so in
political science we've had published
papers on well ovulation and voting do
you know that during certain time of the
month you're sorry
sofie's making symbols at me I was
distracted everything um do you know
that dirty did you know that during
certain times of the month
women are 20 percentage points less
likely to more likely to vote for Barack
Obama actually the published research
said that married single women were 20
percentage points more likely to vote
for Barack Obama but married women were
more likely to support Mitt Romney
do you know that men with fat arm
college students with fat arms or more
likely to oppose economic redistribution
it's it's it was published in in a
research journal um do you know that
elections are determined by college
football games and shark attacks again
this was was all published um now these
studies like these are kind of notorious
in science now because they fail to
replicate now I won't say all of those
studies fail to replicate some of them
failed to replicate others I'm pretty
sure they wouldn't replicate if you're
gonna bother to redo them because the
data are basically noise the data in
these studies are consistent with null
effects or more to the point they're
consistent with effects that are highly
variable unpredictable and context
dependent so I want to emphasize that
that I'm not going around saying that
your hormones don't affect how you vote
I have no idea I'm sure my hormones
affect how I vote I don't think they
will change 20% of people's votes I
don't think they're gonna change 2% of
people vote so I have good reason for
thinking that I think that the
occasional person might be so pissed off
that their college football team loses a
game that they may vote a different way
I don't expect to see a systemic effect
of that size I'm not going to go around
saying effects are zero but I think
effects are highly variable now I'm
gonna get back to the sort of political
point of studies like that um but I want
to emphasize that these problems aren't
just with like joke studies like
ovulation and voting or fat arms or
whatever they're also in serious
research um so for example there was a
study done about 25 years ago that was
recently published was a study on an
intervention for four-year-old children
in Jamaica they had a hundred thirty
kids and half of the kids got a certain
Internet
intervention with their mothers at the
age of four and half of them didn't now
it only got published recently because
they followed them up for 20 years and
they recorded their earnings once they
were grownups and they found that the
kids who had the intervention had 42%
higher earnings than the kids without
the intervention now 42% is pretty good
in fact not only was it a large number
but it was statistically significant to
be statistically significant you have to
be at least two standard errors away
from zero a standard error is a measure
of uncertainty and so the standard error
of this study was about 20 points so
what what that means is what does that
mean
well that means that they couldn't have
seen an estimate of less than 40 percent
or it wouldn't have been statistically
significant it wouldn't have been
published so here's 0 if this is 0 and
this is 1 standard error which is 20
percent in fact any effect estimate had
to be at least plus 40 or minus 40 or it
wouldn't have been published so when
they said it was not only statistically
significant it was also large it was a
statistically significant it had to be
large now let's just suppose well I'll
say this study a lot it's the various
data issues which I'm not I'm not gonna
go into here like some of the kids some
of the kids left Jamaica the kids who
left Jamaica actually had higher
earnings and the ones who didn't leave
Jamaica more kids in the treatment group
left Jamaica and in the control group
there were different missing data than
that's okay that that always happens let
me ask you this what did the true effect
was 5 percent that would be pretty good
if you could do an intervention for
four-year-olds and then 20 years later
their incomes are 5 percent higher that
would be great well if the estimate were
5 percent then the published estimate
from this study has to be at least 8
times larger than the true effect well
then you might say well 8 times that's
that's kind of too bad but at least they
got the direction right but I don't know
that they got the direction right what
if the true effect was minus 5 percent
well that's silly how could it hurt to
do an
intervention well you could you could
imagine it you know all they thought you
know well we're all set we don't need to
do XY and Z because we're getting the
intervention you know whatever I don't
know baby it hurts because after all if
they spent an hour a week or two hour a
week doing this maybe they were doing
that instead of doing something you know
more more useful right inter with their
time opportunity cost right we've heard
about that
what did the true effect or minus 5%
well the estimated effect would still
have to be at least 40% so it could be -
it could be too high by a factor of
eight in the wrong direction even now we
call this the statistical significance
filter it leads to systemic over
estimates of effect sizes it's one of
these things that everybody knows and
people don't know so they call these
things unbiased estimates even though
they can be eight times higher than the
true effect but it's it's a little bit
worse than this because there's a
feedback loop and the feedback loop goes
as follows I'm designing a new study so
how large should my study be well I have
to have a sense of how large could be
effect B so I look in the literature and
the literature says oh this treatment
has an effect of 40% oh this is a pretty
big effect I guess if we study is this
big I'm very likely of a high power I'm
very likely to discover something in the
future so then someone designs their new
study being completely sure that their
new study is almost definitely going to
succeed because they think they're
looking for this big effect then they do
the new study and the data looked kind
of noisy and they managed to find
something statistically significant but
of course they do because they knew
ahead of time the study was going to
work right so you get into it into this
loop it's a the winners curse they say
in economics right you win the auction
and by winning you lose um well I I want
to write a paper sometime called death
of a paradigm and in this case the
paradigm is a statistical paradigm in
which you come up with an idea you study
it you do an experiment you test it you
find out it's statistically significant
and you publish the result and that
effects policy and the trouble is there
are not
so many low-hanging fruit around anymore
they've been plucked already indeed in
medical research it's considered
unethical to estimate large effects
usually because in medical research
you're supposed to compare to the best
available alternative you're not some
the only reason they could compare
stents to placebo is because they were
pretty that they had a sense that maybe
stents weren't particularly effective so
we're actually always studying small
effects we're studying small effects but
we're using statistical approach that's
designed to study large effects and it's
it's not working now at this point I
think the the natural attitude of the
statistician would be to say well
obviously people should take more
statistics classes maybe statistics
should be a requirement for more
undergraduate majors maybe we need more
faculty lines here I have the president
the University here I can really make
the case for that um
how actually though I think that
scientists have been listening to us all
too well they've been listening to our
message and our message is that you can
use statistics to extract signal from
noise that you can win repeatedly even
even my own statistics books have this
flavor which is here's a problem here
are some data here's the result I have a
95% confidence interval it exclu exclude
zero I've learned something another win
for statistics over and over again
that's the message that we sell there we
are telling people what they want to
hear
I had this article to colleague Lee
called the triple a tranche of subprime
science and the idea was that just as in
with the Triple Aim or the mortgage
bonds that there's all these data and
researchers scoop out the statistically
significant results that flowed up and
then they collect them and they put them
together into statistically significant
meta analyses and it's all just kind of
froth but they they get things that are
like the triple a bond which is P equals
point zero five and then that's supposed
to be really valuable but it's really
it's not necessarily
so valuable now for decades for nearly a
century statisticians have been
patiently training the world people on
how we can extract signal from noise
like polling right hundreds of millions
of voters and yet a survey of fifteen
hundred people can tell you about them
it's counterintuitive right that you can
learn you can learn about the
effectiveness of a treatment from a
randomized experiment on 20 people yes
under controlled conditions this works
casinos really do make money the
theorems are not false but the theorems
are only as good as their assumptions
how would it work if you ran a casino
and the probabilities on the dice varied
based on whether the dice were hot or
cold or who was throwing the dice or
whether the person or whether the person
sitting next to the dice thrower was
making a face at the person throwing a
dice or whether people knew that they
were supposed to get high numbers or low
numbers or if there are any other
information leakage all of a sudden your
casino might make money it might lose
money but the modeling would have to be
a lot more difficult um so I think we
have to recognize that we statisticians
have been selling we've been selling
statistics as a form of uncertainty
laundering and it may be we shouldn't be
doing that um so what then to do well
remember the lesson from the birthday
problem which is when a problem gets too
large embedded in a larger problem when
it becomes too difficult embedded in a
larger problem um so here's an example
from one of our collaborative research
projects this was a survey that I did
with some colleagues at Microsoft
Research on using the xbox video game
platform beef in this was done in
September and October and November of
2012 you had the ability to click and
vote and 300,000 people did so here were
the data you can see from the graph that
in September Obama and
they were very close the non Ruiz the
number of people no opinion went down
Romney took an early lead and kept going
and at the end we ended up with with
president Romney and I'm sure we can all
agree that that wouldn't be the worst
possible outcome
well what that's not what happened no
something went wrong it's almost as if
people who play the Xbox aren't a
representative sample of voters we can
compare they actually fit F with
ethnicity pretty well Xbox players have
more they're more young young people
play the Xbox and there are some other
differences Xbox players are slightly
more Republican less democratic which is
why Mitt Romney was winning among the
Xbox players so well it turns out I
don't want to spend too much time on the
example but I'll tell you one thing that
although the data are not so great not
representative we can adjust them and
learn a lot and one reason is because
whether you play the Xbox it you're not
selecting in people's political
attitudes I wouldn't use an Xbox survey
to answer questions like what video game
platform do you play for example and I
wouldn't use a survey on Fox News to
estimate people's political attitudes
but this this kind of worked so we I won
I showed this slide only because like
it's like why are we doing polling in
the Xbox well let's be honest as a
publicity stunt for Microsoft okay but
it's not like conventional polling is so
great conventional Pauling's falling
apart non-response rates are over 90
percent as if current trends continue
non-response rates will soon be in the
hundreds so it's like well there's no
you you you can't stand still right okay
so we adjusted the Xbox poll for
demographics we shifted based on their
ethnicity and their age and so forth and
then you get these this estimate over
time where Obama was ahead then Romney
was ahead and and Obama won this is very
close to what you would get from
something like pollster calm although
it's kind of impressive because each dot
data from a separate day they're not
this is not a running average it's
actually that the data pretty cool we
could do better though because in this
poll we also asked people are they
Democrat Republican or an independent
and we asked how they voted in the
previous election and we can also adjust
for that because the poll had too many
Republicans and after you do that you
get the dark line here so the light line
is what you got from the just adjusting
for demographics so by adjusting for
partisanship that actually gets rid of
more than half of the variation over
time what this tells us I mean we went
through a lot to try to interpret this
but I think what this tells us is that
most of the variation in the polls is
due to differential non-response so when
your candidate is not doing well you
don't really want to respond to the poll
and so your candidates even less well
Nepal and when your candidates doing
well they're like yeah I'll play the
polling game this is fun yeah how's my
guy doing let's check let's check again
let's see it's Mike I still ahead this
is great this is fun and so the poll
this exagerate s--
suites in true public opinion now what's
going on here is that 60% of people vote
but less than 10% of people participate
in polls so answering a survey is
optional and whether you answer a survey
depends a lot a lot on your mood so this
is kind of an amazing example because
not only did we do better than
conventional polls but we learned
something new and it all kind of fits
together and again as with the birthday
example it fits together because we're
looking at more things if I had just
studied one day and tried to adjust it
perfectly I wouldn't have learned we
wouldn't have learned from that
oh this is just enough from 2016 all
this is this is a graph where each dot
was a Paul Allen Abramowitz a political
scientist sent this to me each dot is a
poll and he's plotting the percent
support the the margin in favor of
Hillary Clinton in the camp in the in
Nepal versus the percent of people who
were said that there were Democrats in
the survey and it's like look at this
perfect correlation on surveys with more
demcratas with more democrats you
hillary did better so it's still it's
still happening okay now where does this
lead us we're in a world of big data
okay big data are typically convenient
samples not random samples they're
observational comparisons not controlled
experiments they're available data
they're not measurements designed for a
particular study so as a result when
analyzing big data like the xbox poll or
our modern public health data we need to
adjust we need to extrapolate from
sample to population we need to match
the treatment group to the control group
because it's not a randomized experiment
we need to generalize from observations
to underlying constructs of interest a
big data need big model nowadays I spend
a lot of time with my colleagues some of
whom are in this room working on Stan
which is our computer program that fits
Bayesian models
it's named after stanislav Blum who is a
20th century physicist who with his
colleagues developed the so-called Monte
Carlo method for solving math problems
using random simulation and it's like we
have this big computer program that fits
big models the most important aspect of
a statistical method is not what it does
with the data but what data it uses and
so the important part of a big model is
that it's big enough to allow you to put
the data in this afternoon my department
chair richard davis came by and he said
you're giving this talk he said don't
forget don't forget to plug statistics
and say how important so I was thinking
about that
so math I'll talk about math but like
mathematics plays three roles in this
story the first is it's a substitute for
replication
it's a substitute for data someone does
a study and I can say looking at the
math don't bother replicating this study
it's not gonna work it's all noise I can
see you know your ass - your effect is
no more than this big in your standard
error is this big so math help me math
is a substitute for data it's a it's
that's that's probably the most
important it's most important role in
statistics setting we use mathematical
models for variation how we did stuff
like that birthday example or the Xbox
we have models
you can't just stare at the data and do
that finally we need a lot of math to
make the computing work so to actually
fit the models we want to fit require a
lot of a lot of research there's two
things I wanted to mention before
closing and one is the folk theorem of
statistical computing which is that when
you have a problem with your computation
typically there's a problem with your
model when your computer is running slow
there's often like something that went
wrong that you did wrong and and that
again like it's I'm sort of mentioning
that like a little bit of what it feels
like to do what it to do what we do um
the other thing that I wanted to say was
that about these political studies
claims that voters are affected by
little things strange things like
sporting events and shark attacks a
claim that voters are shallow is very
popular on the left and on the right and
on the left you can say well voters are
so shallow this system is a sham on the
right it can be used to discredit
democracy and say well gee if we don't
trust voters we should diminish the
political sphere get rid of taxes
because we don't trust democracy and and
I don't think that's right and I say
that kind of as a statistician I think a
lot of these claims that have been made
have been made based on very noisy data
people have set themselves up to find
effects so they look to find something
and they find it and in that world every
nudge has a large effect and I don't
think that's does not seem to actually
describe the world as I see it and that
Xbox example showed how all these swings
that you see in raw data when you look
at them carefully there's there's
actually a lot more a lot more stability
so in summary I want to close with I
want to close with these words here
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Ventura for a brilliant talk
and then entertaining one as well the
floor is open to the questions there are
microphones in the aisles you could step
there and just identify yourself and
then shoot your question to Andrew and I
should say before we begin that there is
a reception in Andrew gell-mann's honor
that will be taking place in the faculty
room which is just behind the stage here
so you and you were all and you were all
invited hello thank you
my name is Flynn Schuyler I'm a
biomedical engineering student and I was
very interested in what she said about
the stent and placebo study and how you
reconstructed the data to obtain a
different p-value from the results and
so my question is since so much of
medical research is based on this idea
of drug versus placebo and before and
after effects why is there not a
standard for medical research so that
given a certain set of data all
researchers would obtain the same
p-value I don't think the p-value is so
important so I think we should be moving
toward a framework of continuous quality
improvement which is an idea that's been
around in industry since the 1920s has
been very popular in the Japanese auto
industry for for many decades I think
the model medical research I think the
model should not be we have this
isolated thing which works I think we
should be talking about continuing to
process improvement in which I believe
that the doctors in patients who are
trying out these methods should be more
active participants and so I that the
point is that a stent is not an abstract
thing if people are doing it for a
reason and I think that there should be
in the ideal world more experimentation
and data collection at the level of the
individual patient moving away from this
sort of you know 40 an idea of there
being a single thing that's done for
body in that case the p-value is kind of
irrelevant thank you here dr. Gillman
thank you so much for wonderful talk I'm
a medical student and when transiting
the residency next year your stent
problem was well received I wanted to
ask you how do we fix polling obviously
a tough question but I wanna get your
thoughts on it there's a well-known
event that happened about a year ago
where we got things wrong and Virginia
was I think another interesting example
where the polls were off oh how do we
fix polling well you wouldn't want
polling to be too good right I mean in
the sense that voters do get to change
their mind before the election the 2016
the national polls were or pretty good
that there were certain state polls that
didn't do so well because they didn't do
enough adjustment they didn't they
weren't all adjusting for people living
in like for education or urban rural
it's a funny thing about state polls
that a state poll is as expensive as a
national poll because surveying 1,500
people just cost the same amount but the
people who do state poll like there's a
lot less money to be made in the state
poll because the market is smaller so
what do I think is a solution I think
the solution is to use the national
polls and use partial pooling Mr P to
estimate state level opinion from the
national polls over here hi my name is
Amir really enjoyed your talk it's a
very related question but near the end
of your talk you mentioned about
voluntary response bias and especially
things with like an Xbox poll and on
campus you know there are these polls
all the time when someone is designing
these type of poll polls or surveys what
should they have in mind
from the outset try to eliminate that
bias before they have to take into
account all those variables I think the
number one thing is you should think of
the people who respond your to the polls
as your research partners don't think of
them as like like you know like animals
that you're measuring you like think of
them as like participants so figure out
like what you want to know from them
and how you can ask it and how they can
help because conditional on someone
responding to a poll in the first place
they probably want to help you I mean
one reason why people like I mean yeah
so I think you want to take advantage of
that resource and that's tended to be
wasted
traditionally what people do is they do
a poll and they're like hey we trick
somebody into answering our survey now
let's bombard them with a bunch of
questions but but I think especially in
a particular area like you know not like
an election poll but something you're
personally working on you can get a lot
out of showing some respect for your
survey participants thank you hi
professor so you you LinkedIn you're in
your blog a paper that questioned the
the validity of confidence intervals and
standard errors and in that paper they
pointedly say that we shouldn't try to
interpret standard errors because that's
like to draw inference from statistics
because that's essentially applying a
Bayesian framework so without without
getting too technical when we read
papers should we should we be assuming
that the standard errors are close
enough to what the the Bayesian
alternative would be or should we take
these with more more more grains of salt
well I usually would interpret the
results as inferences based on certain
conventional assumptions so the
conventional assumption like if we take
the the Jamaica study the early
childhood intervention the conventional
assumption is the effect could be
anywhere from like minus infinity to
plus infinity and in that if it could be
anywhere in that range this is what you
can learn if you then say well actually
realistically I think the effect is
probably less than 10% then that will
that will change the interpretation of
these statements so in some sense the
problem is not with the standard error
it's what people do with the standard
error okay thank you hi my name is
Charles I'm a PhD student in the
statistics department and I want to pick
up on something you said at the
beginning of your talk which was my
specialty is
X and there's no such X and it seems
that in light of the statistical crisis
the reaction has been what scientists
need to learn more statistics the method
and I'm wondering well how much does it
go the other way how much that decisions
need to learn more science and has there
have been initiatives in that direction
well I typically feel that every
statistician is an expert in at most one
subject so I really am an expert on
American politics I know something about
that but like everything else like
toxicology or the other things I'm
working on I'm kind of winging it but
you know there aren't that many
statisticians there's a lot more of
other people so even if I mean if every
statistician I think it is good for
every statistician to be an expert in
some area but that's somehow kind of not
enough but again like I think the
original sin in statistics was this idea
that we can get strong conclusions from
any data and that's that and we we have
to avoid that so we have to I mean at
statisticians I think we have to stop
doing that to people before worrying
about what to do next
thank you I very much thank you for this
last quote because I think it's very
meditative somehow so I wonder why do we
need to reduce the variation but
especially in statistics you want to
have the variation data for you to
reveal relations to to show the reads
all the relations but then why don't you
don't wander with the variations I mean
and use that I think something you can
apply that for your state of mind is
that you know you have to sort of
separate yourself from the data
okay so data have variation there's
variation in the data we do this study
and the stents and we measure how long
people can exercise and it's a noisy
measure but I think that probably what
you really want to be doing is getting
better measurements doing comparisons
within people like getting multiple
measurements again the X Box survey
people responded multiple times so we
can have information on how on people
changing their opinion
and I think a lot of like we're often
researchers are trapped in the data and
one thing this is remember I told you
about this feedback loop where people
overestimate the effect size that gives
them over confidence than they do the
next study well another problem of that
is it's kind of when it's too easy to
like win like that there's not much of a
motivation to work hard and get good
data and like so you know anything
you're doing a study one what's the
ultimate effect whether people live or
die
okay well that's great but a lot of
things cause people to live or die so
your data are gonna be very noisy you
probably want to get some intermediate
measurements and I think there's kind of
a negative message and a positive
message I have and the negative message
is that it's - it can be sort of too
easy to fool yourself and even worse to
fool other people with noisy data so you
the idea of the negative message is no
I'd either I don't want to do that
because I don't want to do I don't want
to do bad science I want you know I want
to discover real things not fake things
or like well I don't want to publish
stuff like that I don't want to do stuff
like that because in the future it's
gonna get rejected by a journal because
it's not pre registered you know
whatever it is then there's a motivation
to stop doing that but then how do you
do things right then you have that these
examples where we fit big models to the
big data but you shouldn't think of the
data I was just sitting there being
noisy you it's your job to get non noisy
data or to measure what you want to
measure or to try to do that so question
do you meditate what you meditate oh no
this is what you know this is the
serenity prayer associated with
Alcoholics Anonymous and I just never
altered it slightly because I just it
struck me that this idea that the
variation I mean we do I mean I think
that I just seemed like it was perfect
so that's why I did that slight
alteration and who you are now my model
or someone who can keep his cool in the
face of recalcitrant technology thank
you for a brilliant lecture thank you
for an entertaining measure and thank
you for dealing with the PowerPoint that
didn't can not just before you say
goodbye when they tell you it's to tell
story because probably the best talk I
ever gave was when speaking at MIT and I
was giving a talk on statistical
graphics and the power went out and was
in graphics and so we were just talking
we had a whole conversation about
graphics without using any graphs and it
was great you know so yeah you don't
need you don't need the technology you
can't rely on it thank you very much
you're all invited to a reception
[Applause]